let's start thinking about  repairing systems you know based on all  the things that we discussed and not  just putting a band-aid on it you have  diabetes drug number one then you  escalate to drum number two then you get  cardiovascular disease with two more  drugs there and this is what happens and  it's really criminal i think you know in  the united states in europe all over the  world and you have um a lot of bad food  and a lot of a lot of drugs that people  take and and the whole system is is uh  profiting from it but  everybody uh is going along with the  system and uh nobody wants to change it  and so that's what we're trying to say  like